even before polls opened at six in the
morning voters had started queueing up
polling stations will open till 7 pm
longer than usual to accommodate covet
19 safety measures
voters are choosing a president vice
president senators legislators and
thousands of local officials
as a youth we are hopeful that the new
leadership will respect our right to
express our opinion and to hear the cry
of his or her countrymen
ferdinand marcos jr is one of the main
contenders for the top job his father
ferdinand marcos was a dictator whose
rule was marked by corruption and human
rights abusers
a fact-checking initiative
ph says marcos jr has benefited the most
from misleading but positive posts on
social media that attempt to whitewash
his family's past
but a political analyst says the current
political system is also contributing to
his appeal it's not only about
historical amnesia this is also about
authoritarian nostalgia yes the
philippines has transitioned towards
democracy over the past three decades or
so but you know if you look at the
fundamentals of philippine political
system it's a broken system 70 to 90
percent of the legislature is dominated
by political dynasties
40 richest families took home 76 of
newly created growth if you ask an
average filipino did they feel the
democracy over the past few decades they
don't feel invested because what they
saw was more of a liberal oligarchy at
best
marco's junior's political powering with
sarah duterte daughter of outgoing
president rodrigo duterte who's running
for vice president has also given him an
enormous boost
marcos jr's closest rival is opposition
leader and vice president leni robredo
who's been the victim of a
disinformation campaign on social media
her ties to a political party perceived
as elitist by some filipinos may also
explain why she's been lagging in
opinion polls
still her message of a transparent
compassionate government has led to a
groundswell of support for her that may
still see her search to victory
this is a high-stakes election many fear
a return to a marcos rule would thought
government attempts to recover the
stolen wealth and hold the marcuses to
account
others say it would mean an election
campaign can be won partly by spreading
lies on social media
the results of this election will be
closely watched not only in the
philippines but the rest of the world
florence louis al jazeera manila